le cheikh de montargis est présent un
peu partout dans la ville sur un vitrail
de l'église sainte madeleine
sur les affiches chaque année du salon
de la bd il ya aussi la statue en marbre
à la salle des fêtes et celle en bronze
du trône dans le jardin durci en combat
fut organisé le 13 juillet 371 dans
l'île notre dame il faut que je les tue
ma vie et dans sa mort les récits et
cette stature raconte le combat d'un
livre qu'est sautant à la gorge du
meurtrier de son maître mais ce récit
sur la fidélité d'un chien n'aurait
jamais eu lieu à montargis il ya eu une
mauvaise interprétation de cette gravure
du 16e siècle fait c'est la gravure qui
a été fait à montargis et pas le combat
mais à partir de là ce cette gravure a
été réutilisé dans d'autres récits et on
en a fait le combat à montargis au fil
des temps les montargois se sont
appropriés l'histoire il y à 47 ans une
créatrice s'en inspire pour imaginer une
friandise qui a du chien
la crotte de chien de montargis a été
créé en 1968 par madame lloret puisqu'à
l'époque on achetait des crottes de
chocolat elle a eu la brillante idée de
s'appuyer sur la légende du chien à
l'office du tourisme on décline
plusieurs objets à l'effigié d'un chien
qui n'a aucune ressemblance avec la
légende grande tasse cartes postales et
suit à lunettes
c'est la mascotte de la ville
objectif que les touristes parle de
montargis visuellement ça attire et puis
on va se souvenir de notre chien parce
qu'il a quand même une tête sympathique
donc et puis vont l'emporter partout le
produit souvenir ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il l'emmène à leurs familles
anonyme ce chien sympathique a besoin
d'un nom les enfants de 5 à 10 ans sont
sollicités pour voter il lui en trouver
un